there are so many people in the world
and you know you may be watching this
right now and you have these incredible
ideas and what you think is missing is
motivation and that's not true because
the way that our minds are wired and the
fact about human beings is that we are
not designed to do things that are
uncomfortable or scary or difficult our
brains are designed to protect us from
those things because our brains are
trying to keep us alive and in order to
change in order to build a business in
order to be the best parent of a spouse
to do all those things that you know you
want to do with your life with your work
with your dreams you're going to have to
do things that are difficult uncertain
or scary which sets up this problem for
all of us you're not going to feel like
it motivation is garbage you only feel
motivated to do the things that are easy
we all have a habit of hesitating we
have an idea you're sitting in a meeting
you have this incredible idea instead of
just you know it's saying it you stop
and you hesitate you can truly trace
every single problem or complaint in
your life to silence and hesitation
those are decisions and what I do and
what's changed my life is waking up and
realizing that motivations garbage I'm
never going to feel like doing the
things that are tough for difficult or
uncertain or scary or new so I need to
stop leaving until I feel like it and
number two I am one decision away from a
totally different marriage a totally
different life a totally different job a
totally different income a totally
different relationship with my kids your
life comes down to your decisions and if
you change your decisions you will
change everything
[Music]
Oh
[Music]